Being apart of 'Hidden Figures'
was the very first time
I was a part of an
Oscar nominated film.
You will never forget
that first moment
in your career.
I was a real Oscar
obsessed kid,
so it's hard for me to
choose a moment.
When Anna Paquin
won for 'The Piano',
because I was the same
age as her.
And I really wanted
to be an actress.
I was so jealous of her.
The first thing that came to mind
was Roberto Benigni.
Me too.
Roberto Benigni.
When he won the Oscar for
'Life is Beautiful'
and he’s jumping over
the seats.
Sam Rockwell winning
for 'Three Billboards'.
Early 1990s when
Jack Palance did
one handed push ups at
age 70-something.
Stanley Donen was the
director of the show
and he insisted that
the three
gentlemen gave the Best
Picture Oscar would be
John Huston, Billy Wilder,
and Akira Kurosawa.
You could feel the warmth
and self-respect
for the movie business
in that moment.
An Oscar moment that
speaks to me
was Sally Field's
acceptance speech.
I can't deny the fact
that you like me.
My former television mother,
Sally Field.
“They like me,
they really like me.”
Madonna singing "Sooner or Later" from 'Dick Tracy'
on the Oscars
is probably the best
musical performance
on the Oscars ever.
The moment when
'The Times of Harvey Milk' won.
It made me realize that
I did want to
make documentaries.
When Whoopi Goldberg
won her Oscar.
It was a very memorable
moment for me.
When Whoopi Goldberg
won for 'Ghost',
and closed the gap of
so many years
without a black actor
being on that stage.
When Halle Berry won
Best Actress,
and that was the first time
that a woman of
color had won.
It was quite significant.
This moment is
so much bigger than me.
I have many memories
having grown up
on the Oscars,
but it was pretty extraordinary
to get to have my birthday
at the Oscars and
win the Oscar,
for Noah Baumbach's
'Marriage Story'.
The streaker stands out to me.
One of those things,
was it planned?
Was it spontaneous?
We don't know.
Who cares?
That stays in my mind.